bonjour à tous nos auditeurs et à tous
nos téléspectateurs dans le monde
antique la suite je suis sûr que vous
n'êtes pas en train de dire mais quelle
est cette question de tam-tam canada à
nouveau cette semaine au tour de poivre
activement protein articuler leur
fameuse émission certaines personnes on
n'a vu venir comme ça n'est pas le seul
la fête de l'amour là cadeaux reçus ni
évidemment faire une question autour de
7,2 cette affaire édition qui a des
allures internationales que digne ses
fans en france et alors on s'est dit
pourquoi on prendrait pas la faire
soyons séduisant par cette question très
simple le côté le plus séduisant des
canadiens
à damas où j'habitais au québec pourrait
parler de même le côté suffisant des
québécois et puis si vous connaissez pas
des canadiens simplement
la plage lors d'une pintade en afrique
je sais je pars deux cas vécus
j'ai parlé avec les auditeurs un monde
qui m'ont décrit cette semaine alors
qu'elle était donc pour vous le côté le
plus séduisant de ce canadien que vous
avez rencontre répondait et on en
reparlera très mission de tan tan
dimanche d'abord dans le facebook la m
seulement vendredi
d'abord dans le facebook lève donc à 11
à hors de montréal et puis dimanche bien
sûr pour nos téléspectateurs monde
entier sur youtube